soon the earth will shake as two of
cinema's most celebrated monsters clash
though they fought each other before the
king of the monsters and skull island's
eighth wonder of the world will meet
again
here's everything we know about godzilla
vs kong so far
godzilla vs kong was originally set to
open may 29
2020 almost a year to the day after
godzilla king of the monsters
then the studio pushed things up a week
to may 22nd ostensibly so the flick
could take advantage of memorial day
weekend
unfortunately that release date put the
film against some heavy hitters
for example the 9th fast and furious
movie was also supposed to debut that
weekend so warner brothers pushed things
up yet again to march 13th 2020. even
after that release date was set chatter
from warner brothers head toby emerick
suggested that the release date remained
flexible as the studio figured certain
things out
it turns out we were right to be
skeptical that the march date would hold
in november 2019 warner brothers
announced that the film's place on the
release calendar was shifting yet again
this time more drastically the date was
eventually moved to november
20th 2020 but how could anyone know what
the world had in store
after coven 19 came along and thoroughly
messed up hollywood's plans no one knew
exactly when the two kaiju titans would
duke it out
but then in december 2020 we got some
pretty monumental news
warner brothers announced that it would
be simultaneously releasing all of its
2021 films in theaters and on the
streaming service hbo max
it was a monumental decision and one
that was good news for monster fans as
we now know that the battle of the beast
will commence on march 31st 2021
let them fight godzilla vs kong will
pick up after the events of godzilla
king of the monsters which set the stage
for a new status quo with godzilla as
the recognized alpha among the
resurrected titans
with that in mind we can expect a lot of
familiar faces from that film to show up
during the showdown with kong
so far the confirmed returning cast for
the film includes king of the monster
stars millie bobby brown as madison
russell and kyle chandler is her father
mark russell the russell family played a
key role in the rise of godzilla as the
alpha after his battle with king
ghidorah and the loss of madison's
mother in the struggle only brought
father and daughter closer together amid
the wreckage
it also seems like we might see zhong zi
yi who played dual roles in king of the
monsters as twin monarch scientists dr
lin chen
and dr eileen chen king of the monster's
director michael doherty set the chen
sisters up in that film to be a new
version of mothra's twin priestesses
giving them a deeper connection to the
titans in general than perhaps any other
human
characters however while sources like
flickering myth have reported that she's
in the film her name is missing from
imdb so we'll just have to wait and see
if she actually shows up
godzilla vs kong will have plenty of new
faces to go along with his established
stars
fans of true blood and big little lies
will be happy to know that alexander
skarsgard is playing nathan lind
as the actor explained to the new york
times linda is a geologist and works
closely with kong
and what i liked about my character was
he's terrified he's not brave he's not
equipped to be a leader or a hero and he
enters this adventure very reluctantly
demi and beshear of the hateful eight
will show up as walter simmons the ceo
of a mysterious corporation called apex
one that has an axe to grind against the
titans
and we're really crossing our fingers
that deny guerrera the walking dead and
black panther will appear in the film
according to a deadline report from 2018
she was in talks to join the cast in an
undisclosed role
however there haven't been any updates
since then and her name is missing from
godzilla vs kong's imdb page but even if
she doesn't pop up the film will feature
several
other new faces including julian
dennison as madison russell's bff
rebecca hall is a scientist with
connections to kong brian tyree henry is
a disgruntled apex employee and more
the story that will lead us to the
titular showdown in godzilla vs kong
begins with kong skull island the
earliest set film in the monster verse
so far
that story features a group of monarch
researchers heading to the titular
island and discovering the giant ape
known as kong
when we last left the big ape he was
still on his island having defeated the
skull crawler monsters who also dwelt
there
skull island is set in 1973 while the
first two godzilla films take place in
the present day
at a time when monarch is trying to
learn as much as possible about the
giant monsters called titans
which includes godzilla this escalates
when a fringe group begins triggering an
accelerated awakening of titans around
the world in an effort to cleanse the
planet
in the process they release the alien
titan known as king ghidorah the giant
guardian moth known as mothra and the
massive flying creature rodan
the climax of king of the monsters finds
ghidorah and godzilla engaging in combat
to determine the alpha of the titans
and with mothra's help godzilla
ultimately wins the fight
it's here in the wake of godzilla's
victory that kong will enter the pitcher
once again
at the end of king of the monsters we
learn that some of the titans have begun
moving to skull island and that ancient
drawings reveal that kong and godzilla
have faced off before
godzilla king of the monsters
establishes that the only way forward
for humanity seems to be some
kind of coexistence with the titans
while the creatures cause rampant
destruction early on in the film once
godzilla takes control as alpha the
ecological benefits of titan rule begin
to reveal themselves
with godzilla vs kong this strange
relationship between humanity and a
group of giant monsters will be explored
further with monarch trying to dig
deeper into exactly what the titans are
even as two of the greatest among them
start to do battle here's the official
synopsis
kong and his protectors undertake a
perilous journey to find his true home
and with them is jia a young orphaned
girl with whom he has formed a unique
and powerful bond but they unexpectedly
find themselves in the path of an
enraged godzilla
cutting a swath of destruction across
the globe the epic clash between the two
titans instigated by unseen forces is
only the beginning of the mystery that
lies deep within the core of the earth
more importantly though godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
we also know that a mysterious
corporation called apex will be playing
a part in the story
most likely as an organization with some
nasty plans in store for
oversized characters and based on the
plot synopsis promotional images and the
film's trailer it looks like we're going
to get a glimpse of calling inside the
hollow earth
and oh yeah somewhere along the way the
big guy is going to get himself an axe
we're definitely looking forward to that
while other franchises might attempt to
hang on to a single filmmaker or
production team to handle several films
in a row
the monster verse has so far favored a
slightly more diverse approach
drafting a different director for each
installment in the series the franchise
kicked off with gareth edwards on
godzilla
continued with jordan vote roberts on
kong skull island and most recently
featured the talents of director michael
doherty for godzilla king of the
monsters
this time around adam wingard best known
for his work in the horror genre on
films like you're next and the guest
will be in the director's chair taking
on the biggest film of his career yet
joining wingard behind the camera is
terry roccio who has a story credit on
the film
rosio is no stranger to blockbusters
thanks to his time working on the
pirates of the caribbean franchise at
disney
and as for the actual screenplay itself
it was penned by max borenstein and eric
pearson
bornstein wrote 2014's godzilla and he
also worked on amc's the terror
as for pearson he's been busy in the mcu
writing scripts for features like black
widow and tv shows like agent carter
when we think about giant monsters in
movies godzilla is often viewed as the
most ubiquitous because
well he's the one with the most movies
he's appeared in film after film over
the 60 plus years since his big screen
debut in japan
and many of the most famous giant
monsters and movies are best known
through their association with godzilla
king kong has his own brand of cultural
ubiquity mostly thanks to his first
appearance all the way back in the 1933
film classic that bears his name
the image of kong climbing the empire
state building swatting away planes is
seared into pop culture forever making
him almost as famous as godzilla despite
appearing in far fewer films
it wasn't the airplanes
[Music]
it was beauty killed the beast even kong
though can't escape this association
with godzilla because the two have
already met on the silver screen
in 1962's king kong vs godzilla japanese
studio touhou created their own
variation on kong
with the added ability to absorb and
then redistribute to electricity but
while the new film isn't the first time
they've clashed we definitely shouldn't
be expecting a remake of the original
in touhou's original king kong vs
godzilla the two monsters duke it out in
spectacular fashion at the summit of
mount fuji and for a little while it
seems like godzilla really has kong on
the ropes
even trying to burn his body at one
point but kong's ability to absorb
electricity comes in handy when a bolt
of lightning hits and revives him
and the fight again picks up intensity
culminating in both monsters falling
into the ocean
at the end only kong emerges from the
water but no one ever says that godzilla
actually died
and of course the legendary kaiju popped
up again just two years later in mothra
vs godzilla
with this in mind director adam wingard
has already promised audiences that his
film will definitely deliver the kaiju
fight goods
and that godzilla vs kong will actually
declare a victor
he told entertainment weekly in 2017 i
do want there to be a winner the
original film was very fun but you feel
a little let down that the movie doesn't
take a definitive stance
people are still debating now who won in
that original movie you know
so i do want people to walk away from
this film feeling like okay there's a
winner
in january 2020 the website godzilla
movies reported that its sources had
divulged that mechagodzilla the
legendary robotic kaiju that first
appeared in 1974 would be making an
appearance in godzilla vs kong
and ever since the first trailer dropped
in january 2021
fans have been going crazy over glimpses
of what appears to be some sort of
robotic monster
the same steely beast seems to reappear
in a teaser released in march
2021 adding fuel to the mecha godzilla
fire deepening the mystery collider
reported in february 2021 that they'd
visited the film set in 2019 and spotted
something very unusual
as film critic matt goldberg wrote we
walked onto the set and there was a
gigantic ghidorah skull that had been
wired up and made technological
it looks like they had taken the organic
matter of ghidorah and mechanized it
into some new kind of mechanized
creature
so will ghidorah's severed head be
repurposed as mecha godzilla's or will
we actually get to meet that other robo
beast mecca kingidora
we'll know when godzilla vs kong hit
screens on march 31st 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one